good afternoon
i want to begin by thanking president
zielinski for his passionate message
this morning
i listened to it in the private
residence and uh
he was convincing and
significant speech
he speaks for people who have shown
remarkable courage and strength
in the face of brutal aggression
courage and strength that's inspired not
only the ukrainians but the entire world
putin is inflicting appalling appalling
devastation and horror on ukraine
bombing apartment buildings maternity
wards hospitals
i mean it's it's god awful i was
speaking about this with the
our our
our commander behind me here
general milley i mean
it's just as amazing
yesterday we saw reports that russian
forces were holding hundreds of doctors
and faces
hostage
in the largest hospital in mario pool
these are atrocities
they're an outrage to the world
and the world is united in our support
for ukraine and our determination to
make putin pay a very heavy price
america is leading this effort together
with our allies and partners providing
enormous levels of security and
humanitarian assistance that we're
adding to today and we're going to
continue to do more in the days and
weeks ahead
we're crippling putin's economy with
punishing sanctions
that's going to only grow more painful
over time with the entire
nato and eu behind us and many other
countries
what's at stake here
are the principles that the united
states and the united nations and across
the world stand for
it's about freedom
it's about the right of people to
determine their own future
it's about making sure ukraine never
will never be a victory for putin no
matter what advances he makes on the
battlefield
the american people are answering
president zielinski's call
for more help more weapons for ukraine
to defend itself more tools to fight
russian aggression
and that's what we're doing
in fact we started our assistance to
ukraine before this war began as they
started to do exercises along the
ukrainian border the russians starting
in march of last year
we took the threat of putin invading
very seriously we acted on it we sent
ukraine more security assistance last
year 650 million dollars in weapons
including anti-air and anti-armor
equipment before the invasion
more than we had ever provided before
so when the invasion began they already
had in their hands the kinds of weapons
that needed to counter russian advances
and once the war started we immediately
rushed 350 million in additional aid to
further address their needs
hundreds of anti-air systems thousands
of anti-tank weapons
transport helicopters arm patrol boats
and other high mobility vehicles radar
systems that help track incoming
artillery and unmanned drones
secure communications equipment and
tactical gear
satellite imagery and and
analysis capacity
and it's clearly helped ukraine inflict
dramatic losses on russian forces
on saturday
my administration authorized another 200
million dollars to keep a steady flow of
weapons and ammunition moving to ukraine
now i'm once again
using my presidential authority to
actively
activate an additional security
assistance to continue to help ukraine
fend off russia's assault
an additional 800 million dollars in
assistance
that brings the total of new u.s
security assistance to ukraine to 1
billion
just this week
these are the large these are direct
transfers of equipment from our
department of defense to the ukraine
military to help them as they fight
against this invasion
and i thank the congress for
appropriating these funds
this new package on its own is going to
provide unprecedented assistance to
ukraine
it includes 800 anti-aircraft systems
to make sure the ukrainian military can
continue to continue to stop the planes
and helicopters that have been attacking
their people
and to defend our ukrainian airspace
and at the request of president
zielinski we have identified
and are helping ukraine acquire
additional longer-range anti-aircraft
systems and the munitions for those
systems
our new assistance package
also includes 9 000 anti-armor systems
these are portable high
high accurate high accurately high
accuracy shoulder mounted missiles that
the ukrainian forces have been using
with great effect to destroy
invading tanks and armored vehicles
it'll include seven 000 small arms
machine guns shotguns grenade launchers
to equip the ukrainians including the
brave women and men who are defending
their cities as civilians and they're on
the countryside as well
and we're and we and as well as the
ammunition artillery and mortar rounds
to go with small arms 20 million rounds
in total 20 million rounds
this will include drones which
which uh demonstrates our commitment to
sending our most cutting-edge systems to
ukraine for its defense
and we're not doing this alone our
allies and partners have stepped up to
provide significant shipments of
security assistance and will continue to
help facilitate these deliveries as well
the united states and our allies and
partners are fully committed to surging
weapons of assistance to the ukrainians
and more will be coming
as we source additional stocks of
equipment that are all that we're ready
to transfer
now
now i want to be honest with you
this could be a long and difficult
battle
but the american people will be
steadfast in our support of the people
of ukraine in the face of putin's
immoral unethical attacks on civilian
populations
we are united in our abhorrence of
putin's depraved onslaught and we're
going to continue to have their backs as
they fight for their freedom their
democracy their very survival
we're going to give ukraine the arms to
fight and defend themselves through all
the difficult days ahead
we're going to continue to mobilize
humanitarian relief to support people
within ukraine and those have been
forced to flee ukraine
in just the past few weeks we provided
300 million humanitarian assistance to
the people in ukraine and in neighboring
countries
tens of thousands of tons of food water
medicine and other basic supplies to
support the people in need
our experts on the ground in poland and
moldova
and other neighboring countries
are there to make real-time assessments
of the rapidly evolving crisis to get
urgently the humanitarian supplies of
the people in need when they need it
and we will support ukraine's economy
with direct financial assistance as well
and together with our allies and
partners
we will keep up the pressure on putin's
crumbling economy
isolating him on the global stays
that's our goal
make putin pay the price weaken his
position while strengthening the hand of
the ukrainians on the battlefield and
the negotiating team
together with our allies and partners
we're going to stay the course
we'll do everything we can to push for
and end this tragic unnecessary war
this is a struggle to pitch the
appetites of an autocrat
against humankind's desire to be free
and let there be no doubt no uncertainty
no question
america stands with the forces of
freedom
we always have and we always will
i thank you all and god bless you and
i'm going to walk over and sign this
legislative sign this bill to allow the
drawdown of those materials
and may god protect their
young ukrainians out there defending
their country
[Applause]
[Applause]
what i'm signing here
is
a delegation authority under section
50631
foreign assistance act of 1961.
translated
a total of
800 million dollars
[Music]
going to come in other than
what
is going after maternity wars hospital
are you ready
for the next event